so I'll sort of be trying to provide an
introduction or an overview about gauge
theory and geometric langlands but I
don't want to give the same talk I would
have given a decade ago so it can't be a
systemic is that one would have been
also I expect that the audience is
highly varied in your point of view and
what you already know about it so I'll
give an overview of sorts but and I hope
you'll all get something out of it so
the story starts in six dimensions in
six dimensions for each type of simply
Leslie group ADRA
and here we specify only the Dinkin
diagram not the group there is a six
dimensional super conformal field theory
well the conformal group in six
dimensions with the so2 six so2 comma
six would be the group of conformal
notions of six dimensional Minkowski
space so here we're going to have a
super group which contains so2 six and
it's actually well it's sort of an ortho
symplectic super group io sp2 6/4 well
I'm going to call it sa Watoto and the
tilde refers to try allottee so so2 six
is a version of as a complex Li group
with the ax form of Sol it's a different
form of the really group so8
and you have to should remember that so8
has trial t so here in the physical
realization it's extremely important
that SOA it has tri ality so this is a
version of you it might be less
unfamiliar if I wrote OSP 8/4 that would
be part of an infinite family of worth
of symplectic supergroups
but here it's important that you can
make a tri ality transformation on the
so8 factor so that the odd generators
become spinners of estimate the reason
I'm mentioning this tri allottee is
simply to help you understand that six
dimensions is going to be the maximum
for super conformal field theory because
we have to use the last of the
exceptional isomorphisms among lis
groups so this is sort of the end of a
line for super conformal field theory
and it's the starting point from which
one understands gates theory and
geometric Langlands ok so all I've said
so far is that the starting point for
gauge theory and geometric langlands is
this exotic six dimensional super
conformal field theory and it has two
properties that classically would be
incompatible
the first is that if you'e billion eyes
it you can't not gauge field gauge
fields but germs which means for physics
that you've got to form connections you
get gauge fields that are two forms
rather than one ones of the maximal
torus and the second is that if you
reduce on a circle you get gauge fields
of G which is the group of type a D or E
so G here is any simple Li group of type
a D or E if you reduce on a circle you
see non abelian gauge theory of G but if
you abelian eyes then you see instead to
form gauge fields of the maximal torus
what does abelian eyes mean for
physicists it means moving on the
Coulomb branch I understand that in the
mathematics of geometric Langlands there
is an analogous operation of considering
support at a semi simple at a regular
semi simple element so assuming that one
of those two statements made sense to
you the six dimensional theory can be a
billion eyes and when you'e billion eyes
it you see to form connections rather
than ordinary gauge theory but instead
if you reduce on a circle you get gauge
fields of a simple non abelian lee group
if you're following me these two facts
should sound hopelessly incompatible
because there are two ways to simplify
the theory by either abili izing or by D
category fiying reducing one dimension
leading in one case to two to form
connections in the other case to one
form connections of a non abelian group
so as a classical physicist or
mathematician trying to reconcile these
facts you'd say that if you didn't
simplify it it must have had to form
fields of the non abelian group but
that's precisely what doesn't exist
classically
so if you're a physicist you know that
there's no yang-mills theory for to form
gauge fields or at least if you don't
recognize that fact you should try to
convince yourself later and if you're a
mathematician you probably know that h1
has a non abelian version that has to do
with vector bundles but h2 does not have
an analogous non abelian version but
this theory descends from the myths from
the quantum world in one of two ways
where you can simplify it and understand
it better in a way that from a classical
point of view would have implied that it
started life with what doesn't exist
the non-abelian theory of the herb or to
form gauge field so that's the
underlying mystery if you like of the
six dimensional super conformal field
theory and it's that which leads to
geometric Langlands and all kinds of
other crazy things so to continue with
to to be more specific we take our sixth
manifold to be a five manifold times a
circle of radius R or circumference two
PI R and then the effect of action that
we get in five dimensions well it's what
you'd expect for yang-mills theory where
f is the curvature and the action as
usual is the integral of the square of
the curvature except for one completely
crazy fact that instead of the action
being proportional to R as it would be
in classical dimensional reduction where
you would integrate over the fiber and
get a factor of the volume of the fiber
here you get a factor of the inverse of
the volume of the fiber now the fact
that you get the inverse volume is to
complete the elementary fact that
follows from conformal immigrants the
six dimensional theory was conformally
invariant so if we rescale all lengths
and six dimensions will leave this
effective action invariant
rescaling lengths would multiply or by
constant but it would also multiply the
five dimension lengths by constant and
because F squared has dimension 4 but
were in five dimensions remember a
curvature has a derivative the
connection naturally scales like a
derivative so f scales like a second
derivative so here we in fact have four
derivatives but five integrals so this
scales like lengths so it has to
multiply inverse length so the the
scaling of the effect of action with
inverse length simply follows from six
dimensional conformal invariance but it
also shows that this is not coming by a
classical operation of integration over
the fiber it's coming from some kind of
quantum duality and going from six to
five dimensions it's that quantum
duality by which what didn't really
exist classically the non abelian gerb
Theory manages to materialize in five
dimensions as a concrete non abelian
gauge theory now there's a variant which
I want to briefly mention of step two
which is a twisted reduction on a circle
I'm going to mention that just because I
want to explain how Li groups that are
not simply laced and then
so if G is not so in six dimensions we
only had an ad e classification so what
I've described so far will give us gauge
theory of ad groups in five dimensions
gauge three or simply lay strips how are
we going to go to non simple nice script
well non simple I scripts are related to
pairs once you're at the point where G
is simply laced and I'm just calling
star an autumn morphism of G but for
example the group G two with the related
it's a spin eight and try ality here you
can take an autumn or physicists are his
cube is 1 and G 2 is a fixed point set
us to be an 8 under that operation so
there are certain pairs consisting of a
simply lace group and in autumn orphism
and if for such pairs this six
dimensional theory actually has an
autumn orphism and therefore when you
compact to five in a circle there's a
twist at automorphism and when you make
the twisted compactification you get in
five dimensions gauge Theory mod of the
H that would classically be associated
to the pair G on the automorphism but
gauge theory of the Langlands GN o'doole
group
for example G 2 is self-dual so if you
want to get G 2 gauge Theory in five
dimensions you'd start with D four in
six dimensions and on a circle you'd
make a twisted compactification buying
the water morph this automorphism of
order three so that's the cast of
characters in five to it well that's how
you gauge it in five dimensions those
are the basic constructions now we want
to discuss topological field theories
[Applause]
where I put the words which I'm going to
abbreviate as TQ FTS topological
cornfield these but the first T is going
to be in quotes because our topological
field theories or not do not truly
satisfy all the axioms of topological
field theory they fail because of a lack
of compactness so there isn't time to
discuss it there won't really be time to
explain it properly but none of the
pseudo topological field theories that
we construct truly obey all properties
of a topological field theory because at
certain crucial stages lack of
compactness will cause difficulties so
also we're going to only take a sort of
shortcut to loosely explaining how
they're constructed so in n dimensions
well so we have this o SP 2 comma 6 / 4
there is boson ik subgroup
at if this factor of SP 4 which is the
same as spin 5 by another one of the
automorphisms exceptional or dwarfisms
of lis groups in dimension n this is
physicists call this the r symmetry
group in dimension n you construct these
almost topological field theories by
using the homomorphisms from span n to
the r symmetry group which here is spin
5 so such a morphism should have some
properties which we won't try to work
out today but for example the trivial
one won't be any good
so in dimension 6
we'd need a homomorphism from spin 6 to
spin 5 there are no interesting ones so
we're out of luck in dimension 5 there's
one if
now we're taking a spin 5 to spin 5 and
the identity homomorphism works fine so
we have some good fortune there and
there's one construction in dimension 4
we have we're trying to map spinning 4
to spin a 5 but we have another
exceptional automorphism that spin 4 is
su 2 x su - well first of all we could
do the same thing which we did before
embed spin 4 and spin 5 in the obvious
way just using the fact that 5 is four
plus one spin four as a subgroup of spin
five there are a couple more things we
can do because there are this
exceptional isomorphism gives us more
freedom so there are more things we can
do and there actually are three choices
that lead to almost topological field
things and they are associated
respectively to geometric Langlands what
people sometimes called waffle Witten
theory and - a version of cyber written
theory with an adjoining type of
multiple also sometimes called any Crump
provide it to our people call n equals
two star so for today we're interested
in the Ralphs that leads to geometric
langlands but the same exceptional
isomorphism that enabled two more
theories to exist in four dimensions
leads to this theory having additional
properties we actually got a one complex
parameter family
of theories parameterised by what couple
I stood and I called sigh
[Applause]
and geometric Langlands duality well so
I think I should first say why there is
a non-trivial duality remember we went
from six dimensions to five dimensions
something concrete materialized out of
the Mist but R was in the denominator
telling us that that was a highly non
classical operation now we're going to
compact value in a second circle
so we're compactified on the two torus a
product of two circles and to make
things simple we could think of it as an
orthogonal product of two circles of
circumference two PI R and two pi s so
we build it from a rectangle in a moment
will allow a parallelogram but you could
start by compactify on a rectangle if
you can magnify on a rectangle well the
first compactification was non-classical
and gave us a factor of 1 over R but now
that we understand what we're doing
since we have a classical action the
second step will be simply classical
integration over the fiber so now the
length will appear in the numerator so
when we reduce to the 4 dimensional
effective action we're going to get s
over R times D for x-rays x squared but
you see there was a complete symmetry
between s and r microscopically the
combined operation was to compactify on
a rectangle whose length in one
direction was proportional to s well
it's length in the other direction was
proportional to R so that joint
operation is completely symmetrical
under SNR it was up to us to do it in
two stages for the first stage we
couldn't understand classically in the
second stage we could understand
classically the first stage gave a
one-of
that followed from conformal
environments and the difficulty of
explaining that set classically is the
underlying difficulty in understanding
geometric langlands but the second step
was classical and gave us simply a
factor of s so we conclude that the
underlying symmetry
between the SNR well I guess I should
remind you that engaged theory you
usually write one over the coupling
constant squared but you see one over
what's behaving as a coupling constants
are over s so the obvious the underlying
symmetry of exchanging SNR means that
the four-dimensional theory is invariant
under inverting the coupling constant so
this is an operation that exchanges weak
and strong coupling so small a is the
semi-classical region where classical
physics is a good approximation you can
understand it large e is the opposite
strong coupling where the dragons live
but this theory will have a symmetry
between weak and strong coupling now
I've explained it for the case of a
parallelogram
sorry a rectangle but more generally we
could compactify on a genus one riemann
surface with any flat metric
corresponding to a parallelogram in the
plane so you could think of it as the
you take in the plane a parallelogram
with corners 0 1 tau and 1 plus tau
where tau is any point in the upper half
plane and then the S code or asymmetry
becomes tell to minus 1 over tau but
more generally you would argue that what
we have here fundamentally is a rank two
lattice in the plane our genus one
surface is the quotient of the complex
plane by rank two lattice generated by
one Intel but we could have picked any
other basis for the same lattice and
that would have had the effect of towel
going to eight L plus B over C talapus D
and in the gauge theory Taliban is
interpreted if you're a little bit more
precise than I've been with the formulas
the gauge there has a coupling constant
e which I wrote down book didn't
normalize quite carefully it also has a
theta angle that multiplies a second
term into action and the precise
statement about the duality is the SL to
z surface of symmetry of the genus one
Freeman surface acts on towels Tala
going to a town plus B over C tail plus
D where ABC and D or ENSO to Z so this
description is for simply laced li grips
remember that if the Li group isn't
simply laced then in the first step we
made a twist so in the non-civilized
group we don't simply case we don't
simply have a riemann surface of genus
one we have riemann surface of genus one
with a twist around one cycle where the
twist was by an out or automorphism
that's of order two or three for example
if we're doing g to the outer
automorphism was of order three so in
the non thepolice case we have a genus
one surface that is endowed with a v
bundle of order two or three and you
could define that cell to z but it will
promote the different flat bundles if
you want to symmetry of the particular
construction you have to look at the
subgroup of SLE to z but leaves fixed
that the debates are congruence
conditions so it leaves fix that flat
bundle
[Applause]
so what
I'd like to stress that this SL 2z is a
symmetry of the complete physical theory
not just of the twisted almost
topological field theories such as the
one that enters geometric langlands okay
so what so what's called classical
geometric Langlands one study is the
case that size is infinity or 0 they're
exchanged I should say that sigh
transforms the same way that Tala does
so infinity and 0 are exchanged by side
to minus 1 or sign so that's the
classical geometric langlands duality
and people in that field also studied
what they call quantum geometric
langlands that corresponds to generics i
well and so far in the discussion we
compactified to four dimensions but
geometric langlands is usually defined
by further specialization which is to
compactify further on a riemann surface
see so you go from a for you take your 4
manifold to be of the form of a two
manifold times C and if you think of C
as being fixed then you have a two
dimensional effective Theory 1m2
now in two dimensional topological field
theory
okay the basic things you consider our
boundary conditions boundary conditions
in in two dimensions
form a category and geometric langlands
is the same develop the categories of
boundary conditions that you get for
fixed C at cycle zero or infinity and
more generally at generics I if you want
to study quantum geometric Langlands now
[Applause]
some of the most interesting boundary
conditions can be defined universally
independent of C and Davide and I
studied such boundary conditions about
ten years ago and I'd like to tell you a
few words about the boundary conditions
that are defined universally
I actually do want to but there's one
more thing I want to say so remember
that in five dimensions we had one
theory in four dimensions we had a
family parameterize by psy
so given this you should ask whether
among any of the four dimensional
theories there's one that actually can
be lifted to five dimensions what's
actually almost obvious there must be
because whatever the five dimensional
theory was if we reduce it in a circle
we'll got some four dimensional theory
so it'll have to be either in this
family or us in one of the other
families that I briefly mentioned so
actually cycles infinity is the one that
descends from five dimensions so that
means that among the categories studied
at geometric langlands the one that
naturally lifts to a two category
meaning it comes from five dimensions is
the one it's I equals infinity and
according to essentially the analysis by
Kapusta and selena that to category is a
rozanski Whitten deform version
unfortunately took the
it's it's very hard to make a brief
statement that's limiting so maybe I
should should resist the temptation to
try to the side equals infinity category
is a certain category of coherent sheets
and in general for complex symplectic
manifolds koko-san and selena described
that lifts of that to a two category
that z2 graded and that is supposed to
be the d equals 5 the lift to five
dimensions of the cycles infinity case
of geometric Langlands anyway where are
we going to go so we're going to discuss
boundary conditions
oh this okay yes the only one that comes
from a five dimensional theory so the
only one that comes from a five
dimensional topological thing in the
same sense so of course the physical
theory comes from six dimensions in six
dimensions there wasn't a topological
twist in five dimensions there was one
topological twist and it descends to say
equals infinity in four dimensions okay
I want to tell you about universal
boundary conditions but there's another
building block I wanted to tell you
about which is that we should discuss
defects so what a defect means in
general is that for now in d equals 6 1
some sub manifold our theory can be
modified in an interesting way that
depends on a choice of discrete data on
that sub manifold and on the
dimension of the Sun manifold and here
there are two classes of their their two
important classes of defects there are
two dimensional defects and there are Co
dimension to defense the two dimensional
defects are labeled by representations
of G and the co dimension two defects
are labeled by roughly speaking by
nobody and conjugacy classes we'll get
to that in the bit
so both of them play an important role
in geometric Langlands and although
there won't be time for a proper
explanation I want to at least briefly
mention there all of the two-dimensional
defects ago before getting to boundary
conditions for the co dimension two
defects will be important so for the two
dimensional defects the two dimensional
defects play at least two roles so first
of all we had our six manifold was a two
torus times a four manifold now one
thing which we can do but what we're
going to discuss a two dimensional
defect we have to pick a two manifold in
six dimensions and there are different
choices one choice is to take a circle
inside the two torus times or one
manifold I'll say m1 inside m4 of course
now there are different choices because
they're different topologically an
equivalent way is to embed a circle in
two manifold
and if you remember that the basic
electric magnetic duality exchanged the
two directions and this in the very
basic case where the torus is
rectangular the case we started with the
most obvious invented circles are going
to be vertical or horizontal those will
correspond to what are called Wilson and
the tuft operators in the gauge theory I
remember the basic duality exchanged the
two directions in the torus so they will
exchange Wilson and a tuft operators we
could make more general SL to Z
transformations and they will map those
two options to other options but these
are the basic cases to keep in mind then
when we specify to m2 times C we can
embed it m1 and m2 times C in various
ways but one choice which is important
in geometric Langlands is to take a
point P NC and simply embed m1 and m2
and since
geometric langlands is concerned with
boundary categories of boundary
conditions we take em two to be a
riemann surface with boundary the
discussion is only local along the
boundary so we don't care what the rest
of them to is all that we care is that
it it has a boundary that is endowed
with some boundary condition
corresponding to an object in the
category of boundary conditions and then
we take m1 to be a line parallel to the
boundary living at a point in C which
isn't drawn well when with m1 being
parallel to the boundary you see that
from a topological point of view you
could move em on up to the boundary and
the boundary where they'll mother Wilson
line parallel or a tough line another
line operator parallel to it is just a
composite boundary condition so in this
setup we get what well T is language I
don't know is a function on the category
of boundary conditions
so the electric and magnetic duality
will map the functors on the category of
boundary conditions that come from
Wilson lines to the corresponding
functor of the combs phone would have
blinds and that leads to what's called
the geometric Becky operators the the
Wilson operators are something you can
understand classically the enough copper
atoms as you might guess from their
rather subtle definition in quantum
field theory are more subtle objects
that are the more subtle part of the
geometric Langlands correspondence so
the fact that the that Wilson operators
are mapped at Hooft operators is one of
the main statements about geometric
Langlands now we specialized this
construction a lot to get to this story
and obviously there are different ways
we could have embedded a two manifold in
t2 times m4 but just for fun I'm going
to consider one more option which is I
could take a point in t2 times a2
surface which I better not call em -
because I've used that name I'll call it
Sigma inside m4 okay and then in
geometric Langlands who specialized to
the case that m4 is m2 times C and again
there are different Sigma's we can use
but I could simply take Sigma to be m2
again times a point in C so that's
another thing which we can do with the
same codimension - defect and if you do
that then as explored by gucoff in me
that leads to the if you - the RAM of
ramification and geometric Langlands we
ramification around the point that we
picked in C
so I think that that's as much as I'll
say about two-dimensional defects but
were left with the co dimension two
defects what are they good for so to
explain what they're good for
I should get to what I promised I was
going to discuss I promised we would
discuss some boundary conditions that
can be constructed in the universal way
irrespective of the compactification 1c
so in geometric langlands you compactify
in C and consider the category of
boundary conditions when you specialize
to m4 equals m2 times C but certainly
any boundary condition you could define
for any m4 also make sense in this
situation so if we want to understand
categories of boundary conditions we
should first understand the ones that
are universal in that sense they don't
depend on the choice of C and a lot of
important operations and geometric
Langlands have to do with things that
are universal in that sense they don't
depend on C so let's just start in the
six dimensions well how would we
construct knowing nothing about a six
dimensional theory how would we
nevertheless construct a boundary
condition in my theory that might be
hard but if we're willing to reduce on a
circle we can do it
so I don't know what to tell you in the
equal six so we'll make it easier and
specialize to n five times a circle
that's an easier problem so now I'm not
thinking about a theory in six
dimensions
how would you construct a boundary
condition for that theory when
specialized to six manifolds of the form
and five times a circle that you
actually can do because the circle is a
boundary so you just draw this picture
so so near its boundary near a boundary
m5 looks like some n 4 times 1/2 line
and the picture I've drawn maps to a
half line with the fiber being a circle
so if you take this to manifold I've
drawn and multiplied by m4 I think it's
Cartesian product is then for first of
all that's a smooth six manifold so if
you had a six dimensional theory you
don't need any more information to
define it to define the theory on that
six manifold but secondly from the point
of view of the reduced theory on m5 it
looks like a boundary condition because
away from the tip of the cigar we have a
circle vibration over a five manifold
but the reduce five-month-old has a
boundary so this picture represents a
boundary in five dimensions and it's a
boundary that we can construct
universally what I've said was so
elementary that I'm terribly sorry if
I've confused you and if I have I don't
know how to straighten it out I could
try to say the same thing again
and four times our pus isn't the
manifold of course it's a manifold with
boundary not but if there's a hidden
circle that you don't know about when
you're doing your theory o and M five
that means that away from the boundary
now if not this interval but the
interval times a circle a cylinder and
while the half line while the line can
tend smoothly the cylinder can so any
Theory produced on a circle has a
universal boundary condition now there
are a lot more universal boundary
conditions which we could make because
as I told you the theory has Co
dimension two defects and if you have a
theory with a co dimension to defect
then you can make more boundary
conditions in a universal way namely the
tip of the cigar is a co dimension two
manifold and by placing your defect at
the tip of the cigar without spoiling
any symmetries of the problem you modify
the picture so in any theory with a co
dimension to defect that means that
compact violin circle you can construct
boundary conditions in a universal light
so this theory has well got a lot of
defects so there are a lot of Universal
boundary conditions in five dimensions I
also told you there was a twisted almost
topological field theory in five
dimensions but this boundary condition
actually does not make sense in that
twisted theory the reason it doesn't is
that although this picture made sense in
six dimensions the Honami group no
longer has a spin five so no longer
reduces to spin 5 because this reduction
to spin 5 was because the circle
factored off but now it doesn't factor
off so this is a four physicists a
completely sensible boundary condition
in the six dimensional theory but it
doesn't make sense in the five
dimensional topological field theory I
talked told you about however we can
reduce on another circle
so now we're going to first of all it
will take we'll work on em four times a
product of two circles which is closer
to where geometric langlands actually is
so we're going to discuss the universal
boundary conditions in four dimensions
and now you see I'll draw this picture
it's a product of two circles but the
first one is the boundary of that cigar
so this is now a universal construction
of boundary conditions in a four
dimensional theory again there might be
a defect of the tip of the cigar and by
the way if there was a twist around the
circle there are defects that match that
twist the twist forces us to have a
defect but there's a family of defects
compatible with the twist so that's how
you would get non simple easily groups
anyway since there was more freedom in
constructing twisted topological field
theories in four dimensions this picture
is compatible with geometric Langlands
that's I equals infinity it's I equals
infinity assuming that the circle that's
the boundary is the first woman the one
that we used in descending from the mist
so therefore for every defect we get an
object in geometric Langlands that
exists universally independent of C
independent of three-month surface eight
because we could define it without
picking a C so you can ask what are
these objects in geometric Langlands
[Applause]
if we do come back to find a circle one
every month surfacing well geometric
langlands loosely speaking has to do
with how home or visits from the
fundamental group to to the dual group
boom the gauge group here is usually
called the dual group but actually
there's something called the Arthur SL 2
so number theorists would say that you
have a homomorphism from PI 1 x SL -
unfortunately I'm telling you one or two
sentences about something I know
essentially nothing about just to match
with the physics statement here but
there's really a homomorphism from SL -
Arthur x pi 1 to J and if we're going to
do something which is universal
independent of say they did rather
better map I want to see - nothing
because we don't know anything about C
so these will be home or isms that are
trivial and say but they correspond to
I'm a morphism from Arthur's SL - to the
dual grip so all such possible rows
arise for suitable defects so the
obvious one which was the case of no
defect in other words the one I would
have told you about had we not known
that there are Co dimension to defects
we had precisely one Universal boundary
condition that actually corresponds to
what's called a principle embedding
so if you don't know the phrase
principal embedding for G equals SL n it
means that the image of SL 2 is
irreducible
in the end event acts irreducibly in the
n dimensional representation so at one
extreme you've got the principal
embedding and then there are all kinds
of other embeddings and at the other
extreme is row equals 0
so row equals 0 ok we're all equals 0 is
actually the most obvious one in the
gauge 3 so row equals 0 corresponds to
deal a boundary conditions for gauge
fields and as explained in my work with
diverter following a long chain of
physics papers the other ones have to do
with DRS a modified by a nom all the non
pole means that some of the scalar
fields have a pole they diverge along
the boundary and the principal embedding
which corresponds not having a defect is
the case that the non poles as big as
possible so on one side of the duality
these are the basic objects that you can
see in a universal way irrespective of
the choice of C
so so this correspondent to the NAM Paul
with the Irish line at the bottom dear
Schley is the case that the non pole is
zero but we could consider the dual
boundary conditions where you take the
second circle and set in the same
construction to be the boundary of the
of the tube so we sort of worked out
what were the duals so so the regular
ngon Paul with the regular ngon Paul
corresponds through the principal
embedding so it's called regular because
well without getting into too much
technical 'ti given that i've eight more
minutes it's hopeless to give a proper
explanation but the sort of the most
generic pole the maximal pole turns out
to be the dual of know among boundary
conditions engage there knowing one
boundary conditions for gauge fields
means that the gauge field on the
boundary is arbitrary not constrains
there is a constraint when it's normal
derivative and then all the other fields
of a various boundary conditions that
are related to what I said by
supersymmetry so Noah and dear Ashley
are the most classical boundary
conditions but here no Aman is little -
the one that's farthest from the being
classical it's the regular ngon Pole and
the others okay the following fact is
important this background to what the
operator will tell you unfortunately I'm
not going to have time to give a use
very useful introduction to what he'll
say when a gauge field obeys volume on
boundary conditions that means all the
boundary it's unconstrained
and therefore you can introduce on the
boundary an arbitrary set of degrees of
freedom that interact in some way
without gauge field so you can more
generally imagine knowing Mun plus any
3d quantum field theory with G symmetry
by the way it's G and not jiggled
because we're on the cycle zero side of
the duality but here it's fairly natural
to consider not arbitrary quantum field
theories but super conformal field
theories with a lot of supersymmetry and
these Universal constructions I've told
you about will lead to that because they
preserve a lot of supersymmetry so while
the regular and nonpolar corresponds to
norm on the other ones correspond to
newman coupled to some super conformal
field theory with G symmetry and that's
true for all of these and both there
David and I said what we were able to
about these super conformal field
theories but they're hard to study
because they have symmetries that are
invisible and I'll tell you in a second
why that's importance so a lot of what
David has done more recently with
various collaborators is to introduce a
new method to study these super
conformal field theories and although I
hope to give a better introduction that
I'll be able to are running out of time
too much so I won't say much but I want
to say something that'll make it clear
why it's important for geometric
Langlands at the top we have the regular
non pole and the rule is simple
enjoyment as we go down the non pole
becomes simpler but the super conformal
field theory groans and at the bottom on
one side we had darish light and on the
other side we have no Aman coupled to a
theory that thought it and I called T of
G and T of G is an extremely interesting
theory because it actually is I hate to
throw this assertion out at the very end
of the talk
but TFG is actually the universal kernel
of geometric Langlands so so why does it
have that status
well d-rush light can be defined
universally independent of C but now
suppose we do reduce lensing then we can
go it from a global point of view we can
twist irrationally because
the ersite means the gauge fields are
required to be 0 on the boundary
but that statement with the independent
variant thunder making a constant gauge
transformation on the boundary so at the
early time of your conditions of G dual
gauge theory as G dual as a group of
global symmetries that's what you would
say in four dimensions but now when you
compact to file in a sort on it for
example in a Riemann surface but really
if you come back to one than anything
when you have global symmetries you can
make twists and going around non
contractible loops by elements of the
global symmetry group so because dear
Ashley has G dual is a group of global
symmetries when you compactify further
you can make boundary conditions that
are simply dearly locally but globally
are modified by twisting by an element
of the automorphism group so to reflect
this fact T of G actually has G times G
GLE global symmetry so the fact my
description is a neumann coupled to
something that something has to have G
symmetry in general just so that you can
accomplish fields with no I'm on
boundary conditions but if it's dual to
dear Ashley dear Shaw I admitted G dual
was a group of global symmetries so in
that special case the something will
have G times G dual symmetry and T of G
not only has G times G to all symmetry
but at least in the simplest case that
even has an order board for some big
changes the - that's an autumn morph
isn't it exchanges the Higgs and cooler
branches so if you understood TFG you
would calculate the dual to any G dual
local system simply by taking Roman
couple - T of G twisting
by a gigolo fat bundle and that would be
the answer
possibly a slightly abstract sounding
answer but what off it has been doing is
putting that in a more concrete form now
difficulty in understanding it is that
although TFG has G times G dual symmetry
that fact is difficult to see explicitly
so in our paper we saw J times the
maximal torus of jeetil inside G times G
pole and by symmetry we also could have
seen T times people so since the
symmetry that was manifest was only J
times teedle with such a description we
would have been able to describe the
dual of a local system or the dual group
whose structure group was actually a
million but you need better methods to
have hope to describe to use this method
to describe the dual of a non abelian
local system of G drool and thought it
is work at least there are some steps in
the direction of being able to do that
there's another word I want to say but
maybe I'll stop right now for questions
[Applause]
it's like what clips
how would you try to c2g well it's
actually a special case of the theory
used to your study so example T of s you
to you take it you want times to hyper
multiplets of charge 1 so because there
are two of them there's an su 2 or SL 2
symmetry of the Higgs branch and because
the gauge group is U 1 there's a u 1
symmetry in the Coulomb branch but at
the origin of the : branch there's a
singularity and the singularity is an
a.1 singularity and the a one
singularity actually has su 2 symmetry
so the hidden fourth case of T of sp2
there's an easy you on dual times su 2
global symmetry but in the infrared it's
enhanced tu su tu tu all times su 2
because of the nature of the singularity
of the coral branch or at least that's
how you would see it well part of it
mathematically in your work any other
questions of course
yes of course that that's a buddy makes
complete sense what that say it means is
fun so T of G as G times G dual symmetry
for I emphasize a special case of what I
was saying is that anything with G
symmetry can live on a boundary of a GE
gauge theory but likewise anything with
deed or global sin' she can live a
little boundary so so so we work on C
times m2 but we divide m2 in two halves
is m1 inside n2 we're going to do GE
gauge theory on one side and G dual
gauge Theory on the other side
so here the gauge group is Jay here at
Siebel and to complete the picture along
the defect we need a theory with J times
G dual global symmetry the theory with
that property is T of G so here lives T
of G coupled to G on one side and she
told me other side this is a symmetrical
description but if you like if you want
to concretely see the map from the GBO
boundary condition to a G boundary
condition you end the picture over here
with any boundary condition of G door
and as I said earlier the microscopic
details are different but pelagic is the
same as when we were discussing lying
operators this from in the effect of
two-dimensional theory here we have a
line defect that we move up to the
boundary gives an effective boundary
condition in the j-3 so the functor from
G to all boundary conditions to G
boundary conditions is provided by T of
G of course the picture was symmetrical
if we read it backwards we would have
gotten the function in the opposite
direction
well any other questions there will be
discussion sections there is something
else I wanted to explain a little bit I
say we'll all stop if there's another
question there's something I'd want it
to explain a little bit but it's
hopeless and responsible for people
missing refreshments I think I'll take
the discipline to only say order tea so
there are these ok when I was working on
geometric Langlands which was mostly 10
to 12 years ago there was something I
was not able to adequately understand
so in mathematical work it's important
that certain things are described in
terms of two-dimensional algebras and
that was not at all clear in any of the
papers that I and Valentine Kapusta and
say ok Google wrote at a time and it was
just beginning to become clear when I
was working with Davina but it's the
obvious underside it much more deeply
later so why do two dimensional chiral
eligibles enter in this story so I've
described Universal boundary conditions
on a four dimensional theory but you
could try to divide the boundary into
pieces and produce interfaces between
those boundaries so we could look at
corners where we for example we could
both be rational here
to make sense of this picture it takes
more than I'm telling you but you could
look at it you could take a look at the
fourth dimensional theory or the form on
hold with the corner where you put one
boundary condition here and another
boundary condition here
well what's turned out is that in that
situation you very frequently find that
there's a chiral algebra but lives at
the corner the 2-dimensional Colorado
remember in four dimensions the corner
is going to be two-dimensional so this
is a natural way that Kai Rajab is arise
in this story I can't promise it
explains everything but it explains much
more than was interested previously
certainly now apart from locking time I
can't really offer much of an
instruction to drive it is work because
I don't know it very well but if I'd had
more time I at least would have told you
about what I did so really I will have
the discipline not to try to but there
is a story that has to do with the Jones
polynomial : or phonology on quantum
groups and how all that software come in
come into this story and if you make the
relation connection of all those things
with what I've been telling you today
you end up learning that you'd better
have carotid was living at corners so
disciplining myself to not spoil your
refreshments that's the best I'll be
able to say right now
[Applause]